the Government of Canada has been one of
these primary supporters of Haiti and
Haitian people during this earthquake
time it's been a very difficult time we
have our troops there we have two ships
in a tea from the from the Navy the
supply is able to generate clean water
as well which is very important our
armed forces also have clean water
equipment with them we have donations
from Canadians now individual Canadians
that total more than 80 million dollars
those are matching donations we are
great too to match those in kids have
been very generous in their donations to
the people of haiti also have expedited
the adoption of some Asian children who
were in the process of being adopted by
Canadian parents and it would expedited
that and so the children have already
arrived in Canada to join their their
adoptive parents we are the second
largest donor of aid to 80 s finance
minister I was able to announce last
year that we were forgiving our debts
the debts that are owed by Haiti to to
Canada and we did that last year they
were eliminated as a September 2009 and
we're encouraging other countries that
still have indebtedness with the haiti
do i do the same thing that is to
forgive their their debts the Haitian
people who are going to one-half to
undergo a major time of reconstruction
which is going to take years and we're
going to be helpful as a government in
Canada with the Canadians and support in
helping the reconstruction in the heat